brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi com we also had a big adventure with
no man's sky during the sony press
conference here at e3 2015 I Sean Murray
takes the stage he's sort of doing his
flying he's like shooting a dude and
then uh he goes into that galaxy view
yeah yeah it's like okay pulls out a
little bit like these are all you see
you know what a hundred stars on screen
these are all stars with solar systems
that have planets you can explore and
then he just like goes off the rails and
is flying at Lightyear speed throughout
the galaxy it's like that thing you do
you know even like having a couple of
drinks on a Friday night you get in
front of you tube and a sudden you're
watching like Carl Sagan videos about
like now the universe is so big oh my
god I would see if you like lie down on
the floor for a minute just to feel like
you're not gonna float off into
nothingness and they just picks a planet
at random yeah like you know yeah I was
just so impressive the way that it all
worked and came together and it was just
seamless the way just landed and then of
course oh now I'm underwater yeah yes
just like mrs. III fish three fish based
well this planet III because chances are
none of your gonna find it because we're
all so insignificant and we will have to
play this game for a billion years
before anyone we discover all but you
know that's gotta be a thing now right
there's gonna be this cadre of people on
the hunt for su goswami to find their
III fish and be the first ones to get
there I wonder how long that's gonna
take something in the way Sean Murray
presented it this time he was a lot less
nervous yes just like I'm doing this and
he was quite like like steamrolling
through whatever he wanted to show like
I'm gonna do this now I'm less like
shaky voice face touchy kind of yeah
when they showed the stuff at e3 before
like I saw behind closed doors and there
wasn't like there was an element of
smoke and mirrors with that store like
they hadn't really figured out a lot of
these systems or they weren't like
working properly AB it's clear that you
can always tell by Sean with his beard
if he's been working yeah II guess is
programming here so now he's got his
beard he's probably been like hard
coding for about six months so you can
tell the nail this is actually he
definitely seems like his demeanor seems
like he's more confident in way of
showing I guess it helps that like the
world when absolutely
mental after they've showed it for the
first few times so he's like it seems
like he's he feels like everyone's on
board and they just want to see more of
it and he's doing that very surely i
mean is expertly crafted demo showing
everything you wanted to yeah how much
space you have and this is what you can
do in there this is all the stuff that
you will see and it's just like man
expertly crafted and also just kind of
random and rearrange them yeah this
great undercurrent of surprise like I'm
just going to try to go to this planet
yeah it worked out okay and then he
warps in cool like like yeah alright
this works Oh genuine as well know like
Oh guys you know stage demo kind of
thing I was like then it was like yeah
this dog fighting is trading yet right
yeah we're gonna have all the games play
modes and all that stuff and let's move
on crazy no man's sky on the Sony stage
here at e3 2015